welcome to this video playing God
montez's grand master loosed him off it
is what has he done his rating is kind
of wrecked yeah he's normally much
higher and he has a great score against
me 51 I won I've won one of those games
and lost the rest one wind 5 losses it's
not really much higher rated ok we have
a bishop 5 kind of setup here out of the
chiba nenko sloth generally speaking a
line that is yeah it's it's about it's
something between slightly better for
white and equal let's see it's going for
knight to e for the idea of this move is
in general to play Bishop f6 and e5
later if i take it Bishop takes he wants
to take on f3 so I don't know if I t if
I have just castle I like that a little
bit more because I have chances to
actually keep my keep this grip on e5 a
little bit longer I wonder
yeah i wonder i can go I want to go
before be five in general this kind of
plan but it's not so obvious what I
should do with you to strive for that
Roxy one looks kind of wrong yeah and he
has chances to go for 45 hmm but I don't
like it so much this position it's it's
okay of course why does not worse but I
don't really have a very clear idea what
to do trying to get some pressure on
your form if he takes beat eggs I'm may
be able to use the B file he's got this
backward pawn maybe an idea and I think
I'm threatening to check on your form
he's not agreeing with that hmm I was
thinking kids maybe he's playing with e5
hmmm curious takes projects I still
think this should be good isn't this
good for Wyatt let's see it's really
interesting maybe if five is the
solution for you some position like
board x 92 e five maybe mmm takes takes
takes I don't know 95 is also possible
not that bad his bishops are not that
strong so it's kind of unclear what I'm
doing maybe it's still the better
continuation 92 e5 kind of unclear
it still looks okay I think
Muslim ideas before a4 b5 it's going for
a five thats that's definitely the case
I wonder and I should do that Knight b6
to see for clamping down okay now i can
put this bishop here on this nice active
square maybe be five is answers fits
this feels like a deja vu here i'd had
this at this kind of position before
beach 5 is a funny possibility that i
have overlooked before
there anyway b5 I'm just returning for a
four then what can you do okay that I
did not expect absolutely not I'm
thinking okay now you can always just
give the exchange when I become come to
be six but course kind of hard to
believe that this should be good forward
in some way at least
okay so how do i coordinate check Quincy
three epic green 23 and rock the one
piling up on the D file behind the night
and then trying to open it up later okay
keep keep that form and then work the
one
blackie i think has little in terms of
active play that's very good I have
looked he won Gupta to do this kind of
thing okay he's taking you can always
try to just take this night going for an
exchange sec but this is a very chance
it's it's not a very exciting prospect
yeah yeah you went for it kind of
admitting that you're suffering for the
rest of the game question is how do i
continue i can push pawns them i don't
know if i should play for b5 not sure
about that Quincy five queen e five
maybe it's not clear that this helps and
I don't have much time so going to play
quicker Google a7 is not doing much
let's look it's not so easy especially
with the with the sorry with the time
situation
I 745 that's not good not good at all
ah come on this is stupid what I'm doing
here Quincy five already was a very
stupid move that is not helping me in
the least ladsous his position is solid
it's covering everything I don't have
any active idea
any activity i only have 16 seconds
check you've got 13 seconds mm-hmm the
position is of course completely okay
check nice going for the for the time
when of course I mean I'm just i just
spent ridiculous amount of time in a
position that was very comfortable
position itself is just the draw of
course
no h4 was better bit clearer I mean okay
it's I can only play the the moves that
I have to play check draw our third okay
my blundering the cornea check white
orchids yeah because it's dead the dead
position that wrong but this is the time
control yeah I spent I spent far too
much time of course yeah yeah I'm an
exchange up but it's not it not that
easy because he has the strong bishop on
d5 it's not completely trivial to break
down it's a position that why definitely
I think wins quite comfortably and with
you have time but without it not so easy
um I think I should win comfortably
because the the Queen side is going to
open but I really screwed this out quite
quite a bit okay how do we how do we do
this I have to taking is ok but the next
sequence of moves is really ridiculous
rook c1 Quincy five is just terribly bad
this is totally I can he just can't just
go to e5 trading Queen's would be okay
by don't mind that but I can what I
should do is just to say something along
these lines here may be here for 40 gays
have my rooks are active here I have the
five more active position yeah that's a
fairly easy win actually the very bad
very badly plate yeah i just have active
roofs queen is good on deform he has
nothing nothing in particular it is not
able to do any kind of funny funny
things he I don't think so
like maybe I look on the 735 if he tries
that my cage for Queen invasion I don't
know i have two active rooks yeah that's
I mean the compass on plus three yeah
it's not that I'm telling you nonsense
white is just spinning very easily then
but this does this idea was was kind of
bogus yeah I have to go rook a1 and
invade them I really started to panic a
also at the time and you'll see that
you're probably not going to make it i'm
still in exchange up it's a it's it's
it's nothing that black can be very
happy about but my AF force is pretty
decent okay i just want to be able to
play some quick moves and okay this end
game is just totally drawn but that's
them what happens in this in this time
control sometimes of course i spend
ridiculous amount of time earlier so
it's a maybe maybe okay okay well thanks
for watching